[Music]
[Music]
you can't solve the problem
you will always need to put in
some initial condition and then you can
ask well why this initial condition
[Music]
[Applause]
why are we here i happen to let us be
left over at
our amount of matter and that's what we
really don't understand
how would we make a theory of the
initial condition
a theory of all the parameters
in the standard model that come in two
phenomenon like the asymmetry between
matter and
antimatter welcome to uh the
anti-universe
from star trek to dan brown novels
doctor who
to marvel comics antimatter is
fascinated since it was proposed by
dirac in the 1920s
and confirmed with the discovery of the
positron just a few dear
years later heisenberg the father of uh
modern physics
referred to its discovery as quote the
biggest jumps of all the big jumps in
physics
but there's a fundamental problem the
theory predicts the disappearance of the
universe within moments of its inception
as mata and antimatter destroy each
other in a huge
cataclysm yet here we are 14 billion
years later
and we seem to have good evidence our
universe exists
and yet scientists still uphold the
antimatter theory
is it time to give up the idea that for
every particle as an anti-particle
or would this be a threat to particle
physics itself
is it right to overlook fundamental
flaws in a theory
in favor of neatness and simplicity and
buzzwords
or nearly a century on from its
inception should we stand by the theory
confident that a solution will be found
well with me to uh discuss this uh
fascinating topic we have a remarkable
panel
to tackle this deep puzzle sabina
hossenfelder is an
author and physicist who researches the
foundation of physics
sabine is not afraid to be controversial
her books include lost in math
how beauty leads physics astray and
talks
such as what's wrong with physics tara
shears is a
particle physicist and one of the
leading british scientists at cern
tara's also collaborated with artists
and novelists to explore concepts
involved
including an exhibition at the royal
society titled
antimatter matters no doubt we'll be
hearing from her
why she thinks so today and lee smiling
is one of the world's leading
theoretical physicists
he's been a critic of string theory
notably in his book the trouble with
physics
and has instead devised his own means of
unifying quantum mechanics and
relativity
loop quantum gravity along with others
lee is also a professor of philosophy
and has
written a number of books in this field
arguing there's only one universe
and that time is real so
i'm going to give each of our speakers
just three minutes to set out their
initial response
to the question is it time to give up
on our theory of antimatter and then
we'll proceed to the debate
so sabina well so to answer the question
is the time to give up on our theory of
anti-matter i think the answer is
no and to explain why
let me pick up something that you said
in the introduction that
um the current theory predicts that our
universe
should have disappeared within the blink
of an eye or something like this
that's just not correct the theory does
not predict that
and to see why um i have to briefly
explain how
all our current theories work in the
foundations of physics
um you have you have something that's
called the initial condition
that's a summary of all the information
about
the system that you're trying to
describe so in in this case it would be
all the particles in the universe and
the universe itself and then we have
something that's called an evolution
equation
which acts on that initial state and
tells you what happens at all other
moments in time
and the theories that we currently use
they all work the same way
so you need this initial condition to
make any prediction with a theory but
the theory
cannot itself predict the initial
condition
and uh when we say that the universe
should have been
you know self-destroyed within a blink
of an eye
what this means is that we have made an
assumption about a particular initial
condition
in that case it's that there are exactly
equal amounts of matter and anti-matter
and
those should have destroyed but it's
very easy to solve the problem
by just choosing an initial condition
that agrees with what we observe
presently and that's
actually what people also do when they
work with these theories
um so the actual problem comes down to
saying there are certain types of
initial conditions which we do not like
and i don't think that this is a serious
problem
thank you sabino uh tara
so i'm i'm going to come at this from an
experimentalist point of view
and and to me to answer this question
it's first of all necessary to
separate out what we mean by a theory of
anti-matter and just what that's going
to describe
before we can justifiably say whether
it's time to throw it away or not
and i'm very much with sabine on this
one so
to me i would say the theory of
antimatter
the working theory of antimatter that we
use
is the one that's embedded in our theory
of particle physics
this um the standard model and i say
that simply because
it's made some predictions the existence
of antimatter which have then been
proven by experiments so we have a
cross-check
so i am coming at this at a slightly
different um point of view
so that's that's what i would take is
our theory of antimatter i mean there
are other theories out there but they do
not yet have experimental verification
so we don't
really know if they're right or not so
i'm going to stick with the standard
model
and we'll come back to that later in the
debate as to whether that's a good idea
or not
um so that that's the theory of
anti-matter is it is it time to throw it
away well
no absolutely not because to be honest
we haven't finished doing it yet it's
not complete
um sabine made reference to the initial
conditions at the start of the universe
so i'd phrase this as an assumption that
the big bang we assumed they were
equal apar equal parts of matter and
anti-matter in the universe
we assume this it's fair to say it's a
um i i'd
phrase it as it's an argument phrased on
conservation laws and symmetry but it is
an assumption
it's worth remembering that but it's the
working assumption that we use
we know that at that very early time in
the universe when it was made of
particles and
their antimatter versions these
particles and anti-particles did meet
and annihilate in
the sense of the description that you
gave but on that very small scale
we know after these annihilations more
matter and antimatter was produced
but we know this process didn't carry on
for very long
and less than a second after the big
bang
something had happened to tip the
balance in favor of matter in the way we
see it in the universe today when
anti-matter is very rare
and why that happened the exact
mechanism
that governed why that happened the
explanation that's we don't
and that's what i think is necessary for
us to conquer
in our theory of antimatter before we
can make any decisions about what we do
with it so there's a long long way to go
um for me i'd argue that we don't have a
theory that we know that really fully
explains everything yet
and we need it before we can give it up
thank you tara
and lee i'd like to go a little bit
further
and contemplate what a theory that
explains
the amount of matter versus antimatter
that we see
in the initial conditions because
where we're in as sadina emphasized a
situation
where our theory is incomplete
in that knowing the laws of motion is
only part
of the physics and the other part that
you need to explain
why our universe is the way it is is as
sabine
said the initial conditions so
how would we make a theory of the
initial condition
and related to that how would we make a
theory
of all the parameters in the standard
model that come
in to phenomenon
like the asymmetry between matter and
anti-matter
and i'll quote the american
philosopher charles sanders first in
saying
that the only way we can explain
initial conditions or the laws
themselves
is if they're the result of some
mechanism of
evolution if they change and there's
some dynamical
explanation for why that's a good thing
for the universe to have a little bit
more matter than anti-matter
and moreover charles sanders first said
and i think this is important to
emphasize until we explain
where the initial conditions come from
or where the
parameters and laws come from we haven't
explained
anything as he said the laws themselves
just to state the laws is not to explain
is not to explain the laws themselves
require explanation
let me just rest on the point that there
needs to be
not just some nebulous new
idea but i would follow charles sanders
first
and say that it needs to be an idea
about how the laws change
and evolve leading to the initial
conditions
at the beginning of our universe
thank you thank you so i think probably
fair to say that you
all want to maintain the antimatter
theory but have slightly different
approaches to how you might go about it
just before we
look at the detail of the debate there
perhaps
it might be helpful just to clarify
exactly
what we understand by antimatter and
indeed why some people
would think that there might be a
problem with it so tara you were
outlining
for us the the uh the background to this
is it right to say that antimatter the
antimatter theory predicts that for
every particle
and potentially all combinations of
particles
there is an antiparticle or groups of
antiparticles
it's it's correct to say that in
particle physics which is the study of
the smallest constituents of the
universe the fundamental particles
it's correct to say that we've
identified a handful of different types
of these fundamental particles that are
responsible for building up together
giving mata
conveying the action of forces and so on
each type
of fundamental particle potentially has
an antimatter counterpart
when you say potentially has doesn't the
antimatter theory predict that
for every particle there is an
antimatter
particle well just to complicate matters
some particles can be their own
antimatter version
in that sense i say that potentially
particles can have antimatter
counterparts of course they all do it's
just that in some cases
um they are the same thing yeah so in
terms of why
some people see there being a
fundamental problem with the
antimatter theory it's that when a
particle an antiparticle
meat uh they as it were
evaporate in a uh sort of
cataclysm of uh matted destruction
and you're just left with energy is that
correct
actually we're fine with that that's um
that's
that's the sort of thing we're happy
with happening and what happens after
that is that the energy that
is produced can then go on into making
new particles and antimatter particles
if there's enough of it
so uh according to the the solutions to
the dirac equation which is where
all of this originated there are there
are two solutions
the the the mata solution and the
antimatter solution and the antimatter
solution means that for every matter
particle there's an
antimatter particle against it and the
problem potentially with that
is that when these two meet uh they the
mass is lost and you you get energy and
if that was the k
if it was the case that the universe
started with equal amounts of
matter and antimatter and that was the
initial proposal that it was equal
amounts because you've got these two
solutions so
you would think that it would be equal
amounts the whole thing would have gone
up in smoke
is that it is that the problem i suppose
in a nutshell that is the problem so the
issue for us is why are we here
after that happened you know what what
happened to let us be left over
at our amount of matter and that's what
we really don't understand what the
mechanism is that allowed that and why
that should be
what it is that should make antimatter
just that little bit different to normal
matter to allow
this amount of matter in the universe to
survive in practice
we find very very little antimatter in
the universe don't we there's a
it's only a small amount of automata the
vast majority of outers matter
and where's all of the antimatter gone
if if there was the same amount
beforehand
indeed indeed so it's all part of the
same problem um antimatter does exist i
mean
it's it's not a fallacy or a fiction you
it's produced in radioactive decay
but not very much there's not very much
of it at all so it's
hasn't really got away from the main
question of why if you start off with
half half
if very quickly half of it seems to
disappear more or less
that's that's the issue which really
affects our understanding of antimatter
that's the big hole
really i'd say in particle physics then
in terms of the question that we're
therefore facing
um do we think that we've held this
antimatter uh theory from from uh when
direct proposed it uh roughly a hundred
years ago not quite
and um were we right to overlook these
fundamental flaws uh
in favor of just well we we like the
look of it it's quite a nice looking
theory
and it does have some positive uh uh
predictions which work
will be right to do that or should we be
you know exploring the
the fundamental problems a bit more
directly
i'd say at the start that you um there's
there's
quite a few things in this question um
so first of all
the issue with antimatter and our
understanding of it
doesn't really say have anything to do
with dirac's prediction that that's fine
it made a prediction there was
experimental evidence that matched
against it and that worked
we don't have a problem with dirac's
equation
uh there are flaws in our understanding
though because we quite clearly don't um
understand how the universe evolved
that is a pretty fundamental flaw in our
understanding of the universe and master
but to decompose it and break it down it
doesn't mean that just because you know
there's an element of the universe that
you do not understand it doesn't make
your whole theory wrong
you know that your theory has
shortcomings
is not complete and ultimately is not
the answer
but it might be effective it might work
where in in the region where you have
experimental evidence and where you're
looking so you shouldn't throw it out
from that point of view if it can still
tell you something
i mean obviously if it doesn't then
there's no point at all in having it
now you might also be asking about why
should you one should be guided by this
notion of simplicity that's inherent in
direct's prediction which makes it such
a nice prediction
um anti-matter comes out of nowhere
really really nowhere
just just out of this um
journey for dirac to use the theories of
the time special relativity and quantum
theory to
to provide the best description of an
electron in any circumstance
and out of it you get this idea of
antimatter it's wonderful
there's definitely a history in the
subject that if you can find a simpler
explanation
one that cuts out complication it's
generally taken
to be the correct one and run with and
until you find something wrong with it
and i don't know to be honest whether
that's something in our natures that
attracts us to the subject
that makes us look more kindly on
explanations like that or whether it is
genuinely an
underlying feature of the universe that
the simpler deeper
explanations work better now i'm not
really
i'm answering this theme i'm just
bringing up questions that i hope
everybody else is going to explore
so sabine do you think we should uh we
should be driven by this simplicity
and uh overlook some of the consequences
of that
well before i answer this question i
want to clarify one thing that
might confuse some people you said
something to the extent
that if you have manta and antimatter
they annihilate to pure energy or
something like that
that there isn't really any such thing
as pure energy this energy always has to
be carried by
something so if they annihilate they
just
create another particle it's just that
we see that the universe
usually is some kind of photon um that
the universe
is not only it does not only contain
photons
okay so now to answer uh your question
is there some problem should we go with
simplicity uh and so on
i um i i want to come back to what i
said in the very beginning you were
starting talking about
dirac's equation and that for every
particle you have a
partner particle that's an anti-particle
uh
just that as as tara points out
correctly some particles can be their
their own anti-particles
um that does not tell you anything
about the amount of that matter that is
in the universe um so dirac's theory
doesn't say anything about it and
there's absolutely nothing
wrong with it um what some people think
is wrong is that they do not like um
that this initial condition must have
been so
that there was a tiny little amount more
of
matter than anti-matter because
otherwise as we already um
discussed uh they would just have um
left behind a lot of photons which is
not what we observe
are you suggesting that we should
explore i mean you were saying it just a
little bit more
that's presumably because you're
thinking well if we have just a little
bit more
matter than antimatter the uh that will
that will be the bit that's left over
because the remaining
uh mata and antimatter will be turned
into photons
and uh and the matter will be destroyed
so we'll just be left with the mat a bit
so we don't have to have
the same sort of huge uh split
in favor of mata at the outset is that
what you're arguing
well i i think i'm just referring to the
number
i think tara must know this right i mean
there are some estimates from cosmology
how
exactly how much more matter you must
have had in the beginning of antimatter
and it's a tiny amount which is like i
don't know 10 to the minus 11 or
something
so the the question is really um in this
i i dare to say beautiful assumption of
symmetry and
chart conservation or what have you uh
which we don't know is correct
the assumption is the ratio was exactly
1.0000 okay
and that does not agree with observation
um instead the ratio was more like
something like one point zero zero zero
zero zero
one okay and i'm saying where one of
these numbers is exactly as simple as
the other number okay so the people who
think that there's something simpler
about the last digit being a zero uh
then it being a one
uh don't understand this requirement of
simplicity
and uh without that it comes down to an
argument from beauty and i don't think
that's
a scientific criterion which is why i
don't think it's a serious problem
so lee beauty is not a serious
scientific
uh concern would you agree with that
i don't that's uh that's a debate that
i've been having on different terms with
sabine for
a long time but let can i correct some
of the
discussion here and be a little bit more
specific
there are two theorems that are
essential
to particle physics that are at stake
here and
when you say something like there's a
flaw and
is should we be responding to the flaw
this is what you're really referring to
so let's put them on the table
there is a symmetry called cpt
which means take anti-particles reverse
the direction of time
and look in the mirror and cpt
is a theorem in a certain class of
theories called quantum field theories
that respect
both the axioms of einstein's theories
special relativity
and quantum mechanics if you believe
those
two theories are ultimately correct
then you believe that doing those three
things
must be like doing nothing and that's
relevant
because of the role of c to turn
particles into antiparticles
but to turn that into a prediction
that during the the growth of the
universe
needs there would be an equal number
produced you need another assumption
as was demonstrated by sakharov who was
one of the great
soviet theoretical physicists and
cosmologists
and that's the assumption that the
universe as it expands
is already is always in thermal
equilibrium
so that there's a balanced equation as
in chemistry
so the rate of production of particles
is the same as the rate of production of
antiparticles
and that's not necessarily true
and it's not difficult for the
cosmologists
to hypothesize and study scenarios in
which during the expansion
of the universe it was out of
equilibrium and that's all you need
you don't need to overthrow the
foundations i'm the guy who loves to
overthrow the foundation
it's completely conventional to solve
the problem by having
the universe expand so rapidly in the
early stages that it goes out of
equilibrium for a little while and then
you do produce more baryons than
antibiotics
and there's a whole subject in which
people study how that might happen
and discuss all the ins and outs of
different hypotheses
about it so there's no crisis here
there's nothing there's no flaw
i wish that i love to talk about flaws
and crises
but that's not the case we're dealing
with so do i understand you in saying
that well yes there are things that
uh we need to come up with explanations
for but we can modify the
theory we don't have to have some sort
of radical transformation
is is that is that what you're saying
though it's not a modification the
universe expands
and if it expands fast enough it goes
out of thermal equilibrium
and sacrifice that's all that we need
but but some people may
might say well that's just an ad hoc way
of trying to explain
why we get the outcome that we do and
maybe it's a satisfactory way of
explaining that
but there are alternative ways of uh of
coming to that conclusion
and it's not currently in the theory is
it it's a
it's a postulate we're looking for
the best explanation that's what science
does
it looks for the provisional best
estimation
and this is certainly an open problem
it's not tied
down but neither is it a fundamental
mystery
like the measurement problem in quantum
mechanics
or quantum gravity or
several several of the others um
one could go that way for example you
could say
um maybe special relativity isn't really
exactly true
when you get to really really really
short distances
that's an area that samina and i have
tangled in
is the world that that creates and maybe
that would
undermine the cpt theorem and maybe that
would
give another avenue to make an asymmetry
between barons and after that
there are certainly people who have
written and
talked a lot about cpt violations in
quantum gravity but i'm not aware that
i've
said the terrible lot about uh what
happened in the earlier
universe the problem is that there are
so many other things that come in there
so maybe this is something that tara can
tell us about uh you know there's
there's very little
that we can directly see about the early
universe
so a lot of this comes down to
speculation um
but we have particle colliders right uh
so
uh what can we learn from that particle
colliders can only take us so far and
yeah you're absolutely right um
if we if we have an explanation we know
it's an explanation we need experimental
evidence to confront it with to make
sure it matches
it's um i mean it's really helpful to
have ideas
and it's really helpful to have
theoretical guidance but at the end of
the day
we we need both of these things knitted
together to have a fulfilled explanation
and the whole idea and principle of our
experiments of particle colliders is to
recreate the very high energies of you
of the universe when it was at those
very early points
something like 10 to the power minus to
the minus 12 seconds after the big bang
that's the sort of energy scale that i'm
talking about and we can study
matter at that point and we can study
antimatter at that point and we can look
for differences
in their behavior and it's coming at
this problem really from the bottom
and taking a bottom-up approach to see
what are those differences can we
measure a difference
what might they mean we need help
interpreting this
and that's the stage where we are um in
the experimental field so
lee has the the um
the approach that's this this is
unsolved but it's not a really
fundamental problem it
but it will be solved i'm perhaps at the
other end wondering how i can provide
evidence to confront
a theory at the very small levels that
might
um show it's right or not so for me
there's still a bit of a golf there
it isn't the case that so sorry these
these energies that you were just
talking about that we can produce
uh at uh big colliders and so on are
still way way way below
um the energy scales where the particles
would actually have been produced
right like this face that lee was
talking about is just way
out of experimental uh test isn't it
that's that's that's that's absolutely
right so there's 10 to the minus 12
seconds i was talking about i mean that
is the experimental limit
um so how far we can go cosmology
is perhaps the the theory that takes
over at that point to go back to the
very earliest times but there isn't
there's not direct experimental tests in
the sense that we can
link to particle physics yet because we
simply don't have the technology or the
ability to
know how we can test it and create an
environment that would be representative
i wonder at that point we could you know
move on from this initial conversation
about the nature of the problem too the
question of whether the
antimatter puzzle is going to be solved
by experiment and that's very much
related to what you were
you were talking about there tara do you
think experiment is going to be
the solution to this yes and no i mean
and and i say yes or no simply because
you need experiment and you need theory
i think they're both parts of the
scientific method that get you to the
answer
you you you need to have experiments to
give you the evidence to confront
theory and hypotheses with to see if
they're correct but you also need theory
to to take experimental evidence and
give context to it and interpret it you
can't you can't get knowledge
um just by having one of them you need
the other as well so
is it going to be sold by experiment or
yes but it's also going to be solved by
theory as well
by both of them together lee do do you
think that
theory has to lead here and is there a
danger that
theory just sort of spins free that it's
not
constrained enough by empirical data
especially if
you know our our kit used to uh to do
the experiments just can't deliver
the energy levels uh to uh to test the
theory
thank you there is a danger of theory
getting too extravagant and getting out
of the reach of the experimental chat
do you think that the solution is going
to be found with uh
colliders and big building ever
ever bigger ones in search of
experimental data no
definitely not i mean to begin with i i
was trying to explain that i don't think
there is a problem
right so now i can't possibly say that
we need a colitis to
to solve the problem so um no i mean
it's it's not a problem
uh we don't need to build a bigger
collider um
to figure out how that works but maybe
let me come back to something that
uh lee said in the beginning because i
think that's a that's a very interesting
point
since you were asking about what what
can theory
theory do for for us um so as i said
the kind of theory that we currently use
like the standard model
and also general relativity they
generally have a problem with certain
types of questions
when it comes to an initial value like
the the ratio of matter to anti-matter
but also other things like for example
in cosmology people are discussing the
question
why is the curvature of our universe
what it is and that also
goes back to a question of of an initial
condition and there are lots of other
issues like that which you just
cannot solve within the framework of the
theories that we currently use you you
need an entirely different
type of theory and lee has
worked on one of these which i think
what do you call it cosmological natural
selection
the way i like to think about it is is
it asks the question are there certain
universes that are
in a very specific quantifiable way
better than others and that kind of
theory is an example of a theory that
could actually
answer a question like this like are
there certain
ratios of matter that are in a very
specific way better than others
and maybe there are other you know
theories that can do that kind of thing
but it definitely requires a new type of
theory
but as i understand it sabina i think
you uh you're arguing that we can solve
this problem by
by playing with the initial conditions
and
and uh but how are you going to test
this
um you might have alternative
theoretical
uh solutions and glee's been giving us a
bit of a guidance to his one
but aren't you going to have to look at
the experimental results
in order to be able to determine which
theory to adopt well yes of course
i'm not sure i understand the question i
mean we have data we have theories we
ask which
is the best theory to fit the data and
right now that's the standard model
and there's no contradiction with the
data exactly
because you can choose the initial
condition as
there's no there's no contradiction with
the with the theory so long as you
choose the initial conditions to have
that outcome
and then we have to just check well well
is is it plausible that that would be
uh or is that a well you can't there's
this question is it plausible you cannot
answer within the framework of that
theory the initial condition is an
assumption
that you have to enter into the theory
you're asking a question of the type
like
was this a probable initial condition
something like this
and indeed a lot of cosmologists like to
argue that way
but there is no way we can ever
measure this probability it's a
completely metaphysical argument
it's not it's not proper science do i
understand you're
saying that you you are actually having
a a strong position there of saying
experiment just doesn't solve this it
doesn't solve it
i'm not sure what you mean by that it
has not solved it so far
maybe it's possible it will solve it but
to do that
we first need a different theory so
within the current
theoretical framework ultimately you
can't solve the problem
you will always need to put in
some initial condition and then you can
ask well why this initial condition
and we can only shrug shoulders because
we cannot
ever explain this initial condition uh
within the context of the theories that
we currently have
yeah and so how do we decide between
those theories if it's not something
that can be determined by looking
experimentally
what is your process for choosing
between one theory and another
oh i'm not saying you can't decide
between them experimentally
certainly if you had such a theory it
would also make different predictions
maybe you can say something about that
well i can and the theory that you
mentioned you're kind enough to mention
for example predicts that the largest
stable neutron star
should be no more than twice the mass of
the sun
and that's a prediction which is very
vulnerable
at the time at the present time
we do not typically in science test
theory test theories against nothing
we test theories against other theories
and i would think from tara's point of
view
and you really said it what you want us
to do
is make alternative theories which have
some amount of plausibility
which make a prediction
that's different than the current
standard theory
and one of the things that fire harbor
emphasized
is that a measurement or an observation
that presently has no significance at
all
can come to be a crucial test
of the new proposal against the old
proposal
so the possible role of experiments is
not static
it grows creatively as the
theoretical challenges grow and we're
used to saying
that to test a fundamental fear a more
fundamental
theory beyond the standard model we have
to go to
certain energies and tevs and to test
quantum gravity
we have to go to a certain energy and
plant units
but wait somebody may invent a beyond
the standard model theory
the challenges experimentally the
present theory
in a holy unexpected way
before galileo nobody would have thought
that dropping
objects off a tower was a test of
fundamental theory
and because galileo invented an
alternative to aristotle
all of a sudden it became uh with the
right interpretation a test of
fundamental theories
farhavan certainly proposed a very
different way of thinking about science
from the from
from the traditional one and drew
attention to the uh
the extent to which the way we interpret
the world with our supposed facts in
experiments
is a consequence of uh of the theory
itself
but far and far far
and surely has the puzzle of how do we
choose between
the theories in the first place you know
he st he still got that
puzzle and um i mean maybe tara
you know as the experimentalist here you
presumably
want to uh want to defend experiment
from
from uh being at sea amongst theory
um well i never think experiments that
see i just think of experiment has a
limit it's
it's inability to test all of the
regions which would allow us to
um adequately test theory simply due to
technological sort of
complications and our inability to to um
invent new materials etc fast enough
to me experiment is the ultimate arbiter
to choose between
different approaches in theory because
it is it's it's a fact it it
it supplies a fact that has to be met by
theory if that theory is going to be
correct
so that that's the way as an
experimentalist that i view this
and i'm really interested listening to
the discussion about how this is a
problem
caused by different initial conditions
and whether that
the existence of different initial
conditions is itself a problem or not
to me i'm really at the other end of
this problem and
i can i can appreciate very much what
you're saying from
my experimentalist point of view i would
really prefer
to have this expressed in terms of
predictions that i could then
see whether um they were correct or not
and
and i know this isn't possible um
particularly in in my regime
of experiment it needs different types
of experiment but to me that is the way
that we can move forward it's not enough
just to choose between theories as
you've said or
to apply a principle to choose a theory
or not it has to match reality
this is why i don't think working on the
supposed
baryon asymmetry or material antimatter
problem is a good strategy
um you know it can be solved
quite an easy way there's no particular
reason
to develop a new theory um but
uh as lee has already pointed out there
are serious problems
uh in the theories that do require uh
an improved theory like for example the
measurement problem uh
quantum gravity uh or maybe one can also
add
like dark matter like there's something
in need of explaining which we
currently can't explain and so if you
manage to develop a theory that solves
one of those problems
uh then hopefully that theory will also
make new predictions which you can then
go
and test with um i don't know some
telescope mission or a particle collider
or
you know some some some other kind of
thing it just that i think this
this baryon isometry uh is not is not a
particularly promising problem to solve
because
uh there's no problem in need of a
solution
can we envisage a situation where we do
have a complete theory
of antimatter or might we somehow
reframe it
as something else as you seem to be
implying
what what i'm interested in is what we
mean
by theory not to have a feel i love to
have a philosophical argument
but for example what i'm studying now
is whether and you're going to tell me
i'm crazy whether it would make sense to
say
that the laws of physics learn
how to be the best laws as the universe
evolves maybe much of this is before the
big bang and that sounds
crazy but let's note that we have these
intelligent machines
that we think can learn
and i i'm staying far away from
are they anything like us are they
conscious i think we will admit that
they can learn
and if i can code the
instructions for one of these
intelligent
or learning machines in the laws
of the standard model then
i can envision a situation where the
standard model
is what it is because it learns
something about
how to be a universe and i know that's
sounding provocatively crazy
but i think it's the
let me quote find them if a whole lot of
smart people
have failed to solve a problem despite
much much effort then maybe it's time to
turn the problem on its head
and it might be that you discover it's
an entirely different problem
that does have a solution
and i do think that
it overall the situation in fundamental
physics
is calling for very for new ideas and
different ideas about what theory is and
how it relates to experiment
but i i think we have if we go
there then everything like this is at
stake
well that's a very sort of profound
suggestion
uh lee and um obviously
to to see laws of something that might
change and evolve uh would be a radical
uh
alternative to the way that we currently
currently understand how science
functions fascinating suggestion
uh sabina what what's what is your
thought in response to that
you know i i'm going to say the thing
that leo has heard like one
one million times uh if if you have a
law that changed
uh then you have a different law that
tells you how the law changed
so it's again a law i'm only talking
effective field theory and that's
i'm not actually saying anything
profound i'm an instrumentalist okay if
you give me a theory
uh and uh i can calculate something with
it
and uh it fits to observations i would
call that good theory
and there other people like to tell
stories about what this mathematics
means okay it may be that the universe
learns or the universe makes new
universes and so on and so forth
and i would just say well that's a kind
of an optimization problem okay you can
you can always uh look at it from that
perspective and and that's
uh that's fine with me and and i
actually think that
um to move on in the foundations of
physics we we kind of need a theory
like that maybe not exactly this
but something in this direction and
maybe
uh i i um so there's kind of a related
idea
has been put forward by um david deutsch
um who has this idea of constructor
theory um
and i i don't really feel uh confident
enough to
to tell you exactly what this is about
but but basically he's
he's saying that um this route that
we've been on
um in particle physics and in cosmology
that we're looking for
explanations going to shorter and
shorter distances and further and
further back in time
may have its limits and he's trying
to say that maybe some of those
explanations
may actually be found on larger scales
and
one of the examples that he's given to
me is that maybe
the laws of nature are so
that they have to be turing computable
okay so he's a computer person so so
that's the kind of problem he would come
up with
and that put some restrictions on how
the laws of nature
are but it's not something that you
would
find by going to shorter and shorter
scales
or asking about the initial conditions
of the universe it's a kind of
explanation that we don't currently
think about in the foundations of
physics
and i i kind of feel that we need some
entirely new thought
thoughts of of of that order of
magnitude
to move on it's all right where do you
you uh you stand here do you think we're
going to have a complete
theory of antimatter at some point or do
we need something radically
new well i i'm not feeling really
optimistic after
listening to to lean sabine because
well first of all um i i don't regard it
as a complete theory
of anti-matter it has to be a complete
theory of matter plus forces
and and then as an experimentalist i get
slightly um depressed by this because
we have this theory the standard model
which despite everything we throw at
it just bounces back again and we know
it's it's got to have limits and we have
been
unable to find the limits and the
breakdown and how we can move forward to
something deeper
so i would really really love there to
be a fundamental problem with the way
that we're viewing the universe i would
really love there to be
a fundamental shift needed in our in our
viewpoint and our ability to describe it
and for that to be realized i think that
would be the most wonderful thing that
really would be progress
yes well i'm uh i'm going to
have to wrap it up there i think it's
been an absolutely fascinating
conversation i'd like to thank the uh
the speakers sabina hossenfelder tara
shears and lee smerlin for
a properly fascinating debate at the
very edge of
where we currently stand understand
contemporary physics
thank you for more debates talks and
interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv